dingue merci président ces réformes si
elles sont présentés et adoptés
rapidement vont permettre en tous les
cas on l'espère enfin à l'europe mais
surtout aux états et spécialement à ce
que la géographie européenne à placer
aux frontières extérieures de l'union de
gérer d'accueillir de façon responsable
de façon solidaire humaine et avec
dignité les personnes qui fuient la
guerre et la violence
le premier paquet de mesures avec la
réforme d'ampleur du règlement de dublin
est sans doute plus significatif et nous
le réclamions depuis de longs mois
ainsi si la commission au fond a rempli
une partie importante du contrat avec le
bémol que j'apporte en écho à cécilia et
d'autres collègues sur l'accueil des
mineurs non accompagnés
c'est en revanche le moment ici de faire
un appel clair aux états car le blocage
des états a abouti à ce que tout le
travail finalement sur le paquet asile
qui s'est déroulée négocier de 2008 à
2012 était et si l inachevé que à peine
après deux années nous soyons obligés de
le réformer
cette constance dans les blocages dans
les atermoiements heures sont mortifères
temps pour les réfugiés que pour les
citoyens nos concitoyens qui attendent
autre chose de l'europe je vous remercie
et une minute jusqu'à que la solidarité
dos de compufirst m cheikh wade refuse
application notre famille